andy you you've been on both sides of
the camera so much you must have an idea
when you're making something how it's
going to go and you called this a
masterpiece late last year when did you
know and how did you know that's what
this was going to be
because i trust matt implicitly with
everything that that he comes into
contact with you know as a filmmaker
he's so
um he's he works from the inside out and
and from the moment that he started
writing this and i i sort of
saw it was during during post-production
on war for the planet of the apes he
started to talk to me about this movie
and then and then sort of after that i
sort of saw him in various different
stages during the writing process and
then of course when we started making
the movie and i could see that
everything he talked about was literally
coming to life the choice of production
design the cinematography the the
casting everything
it was it just felt so authentic and
real and fresh and this gotham that he
was creating was was was so new and and
yet relatable to but very mythic so so i
i i kind of you get a feeling when
you're working on something that that
that is that that feels authentic and
this was it
being cast as batman seems to be a bit
of a double-edged sword
you know that that after gets all the
attention but there's a lot of
expectation as well robert seems to be
handling it so smoothly when you were
working together what did you see from
him in terms of how he was able to put
together this character of bruce wayne
and also batman
i mean
he's so
i i just really adore his acting and and
have seen him you know watched him go
from the the twilight franchise to
through all of the independent movies
that he's worked on and make really
interesting choices in terms of
characters he wants to play so to to
actually get the chance to work with him
on on
on this movie where he he plays the that
kind of vulnerability and
uh you know fractured broken
nihilistic character as bruce and then
and then this power and huge power and
strength and
you know
resolve as batman
it was it was it was fantastic to be in
the room with him and to get the
opportunity to play off him
now because i'm pretty sure you are the
guy with the power to get this done i'm
going to put this out there i want to
see a multiversal alfred movie with you
and jeremy irons and michael caine
together
if we're talking about this right now
what's the adventure that the three year
are going on what are these alfred's
going to do
wow
we are gonna um
well we probably have to sit down and
crack lots of codes together first uh
you know i think there'd be a lot of
code cracking and then and then we'd
have to come up with something with that
we'd have to come up with a new
batmobile that we all can collectively
you know help him then
i love that and finally you know we're
seeing you in all of these projects for
me
it's like the things that i would
love to see on screen as a kid and
you're in all of them you're doing all
of them is that just your approach to
your career at this point you're seeing
stuff that you love and you're like yup
i'm doing that
i i listen i just feel incredibly lucky
to to be asked to be in these things i
mean i i really genuinely you know you
don't set out to to to do anything i
think in the in well if you're a
filmmaker yes you set out to choose
projects that you want to direct but as
an actor you know opportunities come
along and and and i've been very
fortunate to to have been involved in
all of these different worlds and get to
play
you know extraordinary characters in in
extraordinary and
canvases that's that's
there's a certain amount of luck to it
but i really really enjoyed doing this
one this was amazing
well thank you so much for your time
good to see you
you